[Music]
well for more than a year the housing
market has been booming finding
affordable homes difficult now people
looking to buy are investing into model
homes also known as a mobile homes mary
jane belliesa joins us live from the
southwest valley at the flamingo west
mobile community to explain how these
homes could reshape the housing market
yeah that's absolutely right christian
flamingo west here on flamingo and
cimarron is just one of the many mobile
home communities appealing to potential
home buyers all with the choice of
amenities customization and
affordability
in an oversaturated housing market
mobile homes are helping cut costs ted
cooper says it's helped him he's had his
mobile home for two years now compared
to a stick built home is a fraction of
the cost the taxes are cheaper the lots
are usually smaller so the maintenance
is a lot less
and and it's a nice area i compared the
cost of some mobile home parks in the
valley depending on the year and size of
the home costs can run anywhere from
thirty thousand for a one bedroom one
bath in el dorado estates or up to a
hundred and fifty thousand for a three
bedroom and mountain view mobile home
park andre alpha owns vegas mobile homes
he says 70 percent of the buyers choose
these homes because it fits their
finances the need for quality and
affordable housing has never been
greater than it is right now especially
with how overheated the housing market
is
right now we're seeing more and more
people shift away from conventional
site-built homes and explore
manufactured homes as an option jean
parrott has managed el dorado estate's
mobile home park since 1996. she adds
the process of traditional home buying
goes beyond four walls a lot of people
don't realize that these are not the
trailer homes of yesteryear these are
homes that in some cases look better
than site-built homes because they have
the quality control during the building
process that some site build homes just
don't have
property owners also tell me they expect
mobile home interest to continue
steadily increase over the next couple
of years especially with all the
financial concerns brought on by the
pandemic reporting from cimarron and
flamingo mary jane balleza live local
now